this talk is called isolation without
containers if you're expecting this to
be a talk about containers I am going to
greatly disappoint you you might be in
the wrong place it's okay
this talk is much more about the concept
of isolation and then we can also get
into some like cool compiler stuff so
that's that's neat so hi I work at
fastly which is a content delivery
network or a more of like an edge
computing network at this point to be
honest with the stuff that we're doing
lately I'm the CTO there and you can
follow me on the Internet here you can
argue with me
I enjoy being yelled at it's fine great
so this book I say that it's about
isolation and not really about
containers what is what this is really
about actually is about multi-tenancy
it's only about isolation because what
we need to provide like a working
environment for a multi-tenant thing is
isolation you isolate in between
customers and services and all these
different things right and so the
obvious first question here is like what
what is isolation like what do I mean
when I say that because there's a bunch
of different ways that we talk about
something like isolation one of those is
like resource isolation
you might hear this in with regards to
like containers actually you can there's
process isolation which literally just
the process model there's fault
isolation there's software fault
isolation as well and there's lots of
different ways to do this right so I'm
just gonna be talking about one
particular kind after we go through like
the the concept right so the way that I
look at the the concept of isolation is
that it's really about being able to run
some code without it affecting other
running code in unexpected ways which is
a vague statement but it's fine so part
of that is resource isolation and we'll
talk about that more in a little bit and
why it's not just about efficient use of
resources but what I actually enjoy like
what I what I like that there's a
concept called
FTIR it's not does anyone actually knit
has anyone heard of FTIR before no one
yes great so this is the FTIR stands for
fault detection isolation and recovery
so it's a concept from control
engineering
it's usually referring to monitoring
things like thermal signatures and
vibrations and oscillations and so on so
it doesn't apply directly but more in a
metaphorical way to what we're talking
about I like it because it separates out
the three stages detection isolation and
recovery detection implies being able to
tell when a fault has actually occurred
which is less trivial than it might seem
at first isolation in our world means
being able to prove that when a fault
does occur that it's like blast radius
is known and limited right and then
recovery for us anyway means being able
to ensure that the execution can be
restarted and that the system continues
with the rest of the with the rest of
the tenants being like oblivious that a
problem has actually even occurred at
all right so in in a program and a
computer program I think and I don't
have like you know papers and such to
back this up but in my mind the way that
I think about this is that it kind of
comes down to two things one is control
flow and the other one is memory safety
when I say control flow what I'm talking
about here is the the analysis of the
set of possible paths that an execution
of a program can take right when I say
data flow what I mean is the analysis of
locations that a program can be storing
and retrieving data from and memory I my
conjecture here is that if you can work
out these two things you've essentially
solved two most isolation problems
interesting side note here is that you
know as well see you later you can
actually reduce these down to one thing
if you really think about it hard enough
which is memory safety but it's fine
let's talk about it okay so what we're
really talking about here is okay so
let's say we're executing a function
right and it's really about being able
to prove that that function can write to
one particular area and can't write to
one another area and likewise it can
call another function or can take a
particular path and proving also that it
can't take certain paths when you
examine what guarantees if any you have
for control flow integrity and memory
safety what you get out is a fault
domain
right a faulty main is the answer to the
question like if this program just like
[ __ ] blew up what would happen like
which things would also blow up along
with it right what could possibly be
touched so phone isolation is really
about reducing the set of possible
faults to something that is knowable and
recoverable
for instance if certain code should not
be able to be executed fault isolation
is about being able to prove that it's
either not possible or that if it is
possible then when it occurs we can
catch it and prevent it from actually
like falling through before any harm is
done right okay so the the problem that
we set out to solve at fastly for this
that my team at fastly set out to solve
here was an interesting one because what
we wanted to do was isolate every
individual request that flows through
our network right and so we're talking
about like seven million requests per
second at this point we want to isolate
each individual one of them so that like
the code that is being run along with
them if that blows up like we want to
just have that one request die and
nothing else be affected so each of our
servers is doing like tens of thousands
of requests per second per server and
like the lifetime of these requests is
typically like well under five
milliseconds so this becomes difficult
pretty quickly like if you've tried to
spin up processes or containers in that
kind of speed like that's that's really
pushing it so yeah the obvious question
is what how how could you possibly do
this so one of the first things like
let's talk about like how processes work
right like what what actually does a
process so that's what a process is that
is the task struct from the Linux kernel
it so the the question have what does a
process turns out to be fairly
complicated but we can actually like
boil it down to a few things so what we
have here is you have memory and you
have the metadata in the kernel that is
associated with a process right like
that task struct that we were just
looking at that's the metadata that's
the data that is associated with a
process that lives on the kernel side of
the memory boundary right
from a processes perspective all it
actually has is memory like that's all
process actually is that and that that
simple little thing is actually like the
crux of process based isolation the the
memory region is by default anyway like
the fault domain of a process that's it
that's all it is yeah so like the
biggest component of process based
isolation is this idea of virtual memory
virtual memory uses like the hardware
mmm you and the kernels VM a systems to
give each process like a an illusion of
having its own memory space like there's
nothing else on the computer there's
nothing else there that it can touch
unless of course you explicitly share
things yeah so so another key part of
this is something that probably seems
entirely obvious but the the fact that
code and data live in the same space
like we kind of take this for granted
but like the fact that that is the case
has interesting implications right so
process places the process based
isolation works because if the only
thing a process has access to is its own
memory and that is also where the code
lives then we don't really need to worry
about control flow we don't really have
to think about it basically like the
inside of a process can be complete
chaos and it's fine so it's interesting
because it really strongly ties us to
the safety properties of the virtual
memory though and so like when the
specter attacks came out earlier this
year I think this is one of the reasons
why it was like such an enormous deal
right because everything that we rely on
is around virtual memory and so if you
have an attack that breaks the virtual
memory like abstraction like everything
is going to hell so yeah I think this is
a side note as to why I think Spectre
was like such an important thing ok the
other thing that processes have access
to is an interface with the kernel which
is just calls write calls that affect
the process itself or like allow it to
communicate with other processes or
other computers so it's via sis calls
that we give processes the ability to
interact with other
things in the system and with other
processes right so this is an
interesting thing because if I say all
right I want to map some piece of like
some file in a shared way and then I try
to and map it again from another place
okay
now we're actually sharing information
right and so now the fault domain of
each of these individual processes now
includes each other so you can pretty
easily start to like break this like
this virtual memory like isolation model
right and it turns out that containers
actually follow like almost the exact
same ideas but they apply like further
resource isolation things to it so like
pin namespaces and syscalls and so on
right but the basic idea is really the
same so let's talk about something
entirely different let's talk about
dynamic libraries and dynamic linking so
this is literally what I mean
so if you're in a process and you deal
open something into it like what does
that actually do right dynamic libraries
provide us a way to like load new code
into an existing process from outside
right we can deal open a shared object
locate a function inside of it and like
execute it directly within the address
space of like one of these processes
right and so you might think about like
loading dynamic libraries in a similar
way to how we're talking about processes
right so you know you have the symbols
inside the process and you have the
symbols that you just loaded into it and
so of course you know we start to
develop like almost like in a weird way
like a sis call interface right where
you have some undefined symbol in a
dynamic library which the process then
provides so you have like this interface
likewise
like the process can use DL sim to grab
a specific function out of the library
right the issue here is that it's not
really like processes at all which might
be obvious to everyone here those
interfaces exist and you can use them
but the problem is that those interfaces
are actually just a convenience right
like they're actually all living
together with no boundaries at all so if
you load multiple libraries there's
nothing that stops it from just you know
reaching into like one piece of memory
somewhere or reaching back and forth
here or
you know just jumping all over the place
it's [ __ ] chaos is what it is right
so like this doesn't actually like this
doesn't actually provide us any of the
isolation that we would be hoping for so
why do people use this then even inside
of fastly right now like the way that we
handle like loading you know customers
configurations is actually by compiling
them into a shared object and loading it
into our server at like while it's
running and the reason that works of
course is that like we provide like
semantic safety guarantees that unlike
on the language itself right but at this
layer of things there is like
essentially like no safety at all so why
do people do it this way and the answer
like really just comes down to overhead
so if I were to have two different ways
of doing like communication between
processes between pieces of code you
know if you were actually separating
them by process then you're going to be
going through the kernel for each
individual thing which takes a long time
if you're talking about tens of
thousands of requests per second you
know meanwhile a library can just be
like I just wanna call that thing over
there like zero interface with the
kernel at all right so this is kind of
why people do that but the the issue of
course is safety right the the the
problem here is like we have traditional
isolation which is like often two heavy
weights for like for these small tenants
that have like very strict latency
guarantees right so doing it in the
traditional way doesn't necessarily work
so what are we to do one way to address
this is to provide isolation at a higher
level which is what I was kind of saying
that we do with with the programming
language that people often use to
configure our CDN right we provide
semantic safety at the language level
right so you can do it via higher level
isolation but what if we wanted to do it
in a more general way what if we wanted
to do it such that like you didn't have
to write in my language you could
instead bring whatever language you want
as long as we can compile it in some way
and this is where web assembly comes
into it
so one of the interesting things about
there's several really interesting
things about webassembly but one that is
particularly interesting to me is this
concept of like linear memory
all right so webassembly has this is by
the way like a complete web assembly
module here like we have our code there
then the middle like the function main
we're importing a puts function as well
and then down to the very bottom we're
saying okay I'm going to use one page of
memory and here's some data that I want
to exist in that when I start up right
so oh yeah I said these things already
okay great
so one of the key differences between
like a web assembly instance and a
regular process is that well so you
remember like the the whole thing with
virtual memory and the like the fact you
have the code inside of it
well what would simply doesn't do that
it does it entirely differently like we
actually separate out the code from the
memory when it comes to a web let's have
web assembly instance so we have the
code that is doesn't even have access to
itself all it has access to is the
linear memory and it interface with the
outside world so the goal of this is to
constrain the fault domain so if we have
many of these that are running in a
single process and we can somehow
guarantee that they are going to stick
inside of there like little region of
memory then we can make that little
region of memory be the entire fault
domain for one of these processes one of
these instances rather we're gonna skip
this part so I added more things I
forgot to take that out okay so given
that you can only call functions with
the host environment has allowed you to
via that import interface and you have
no way of referring to locations within
your own code right because it's
separate from the memory and by
extension you have no way of doing
things like computed go to x' which
could send you wherever you want control
flow is something that like webassembly
actually provides if we can use web
assembly in a system like this it would
provide control flow integrity likewise
we also get memory safety from web
assembly so linear memory inside of web
assembly is based on 32 bit pointers
so essentially like the maximum amount
of memory that a webassembly instance
can have is four gigabytes and we just
like so you refer to that as you refer
to that with these 32-bit pointers
instead of 64-bit and the reason for
that is that it makes balance checking a
lot easier which we'll go into right so
in other words with webassembly you can
actually reduce the set of data and
memory related false to one that is
knowable and non-fatal for a process
cool okay great so if we can compile our
crude web assembly then we can actually
get the safety that we need and it turns
out that like clang go rust and others
all have webassembly backends now and
this to me is actually one of the most
exciting things about something like web
assembly it's the fact that it is as far
as I know the first time that we have as
a community like an intermediate
representation that most people have
like a lot of lists for languages have
actually agreed upon and one that
provides safety guarantees right like
that's something that we've never
actually had before which is why this is
very exciting to me so great we can take
our code we can compile it to a web
assembly as long as as long as you have
already in a language that you can
compile the web assembly great we can
bring that along we can use that but of
course that's only half the story we
still have to compile the web assembly
to native code so how do we do that
given the fact that the only existing
web assembly like compilers are built
into browsers and are Forge it's as
opposed to for ahead of time compilation
like we care about here and of course
the native code has to be fast because
again we're doing tens of thousands of
requests per second per server so what
we've been working on and I will say in
advance here that this is not yet open
source or at least not completely open
source but will be very soon so again
follow me
I will undoubtedly tweet things about it
what we've been working on is a compiler
that takes web assembly and turns it
into native object code as well as a
runtime that lets you run the thing so
at its core the runtime actually looks a
lot like this thing that we just talked
about how incredibly unsafe it was but
when you have a run
that provides certain guarantees and you
have a compiler that like works with
that runtime to provide other set of
guarantees you can actually make this
entirely safe the interesting thing
about this is that like the objects that
we output actually look exactly like
regular like elf libraries right so
you're taking webassembly code that was
meant to run in a browser and turning it
into a actual just normal shared object
just like any other shared object on
your system but there are a few
differences there are some like
interesting bits here and so this is
where I'm gonna eventually get into some
assembly I hope that everyone here is
prepared for some x86 64 but two of the
like to the bigger differences between
the libraries that we output and like a
normal library involves the calling
convention and something called trap
tables so I'm gonna talk about this so
sorry about calling convention there's
actually only one minor difference
between like calling one of our web
assembly libraries versus calling a
function in any other in any other
normal way right so the primary
difference is this is that when you call
a web assembly function and ahead of
time compile of assembly function with
this already I is sets you something
called the VM context so what this does
is it allows you to this is the thing
that actually causes the sandboxing to
work right so all memory addressing
happens via this virtual machine context
so what that looks like is this
essentially what we have here is this is
this is the fault domain for for one of
our instances so we have the metadata
associated with it and the linear memory
much in the same way as processes work
right and that VM context points to
there exactly that and so what that
means is that as execution is
progressing you can take that pointer
and go upward and find things like
tables and Global's and other metadata
that's associated with this instance or
you can go down and get to the memory
and so that is like the actual like one
piece of information you need in order
to Samba
this code at runtime anyway so what that
also means of course is that memory is
all vectored memory addressing is all
vectored through that particular vm
contacts members because the memory is
downward from the from that context
pointer that means that every any time
that we would want to access a
particular address we do it via this
context right so that being the context
okay you know talking about the other
parts that actually makes this work in a
safe way and that's something called
trap tables so imagine that we have a
web assembly operation that looks
something like this
what this essentially is saying is just
okay I want to load an i-32 and 32-bit
integer from memory and I want to get
that from the local variable number zero
so that the address of this is in local
variable number zero what this ends up
looking like is that machine code eight
bo7
which becomes this which is essentially
again we are vectoring through the VM
context and putting it in our ax however
what this also does is we need to be
able to we need to be able to bounce
check this right and so that's that's
the other key part of this that that
makes running this code safe is that all
of the memory operations that we do our
bounds checked but of course bounds
checking is slow right but we will get
into that in a little bit the the
interesting thing here is that when
we're compiling this we know that this
is something that could trap we know
that this is something that could go out
of bounds and could blow up right
because we don't know what address is
actually going to be looking for
initially so what we do is we say okay
this is a site that could trap this is a
particular operation that is capable of
trapping so we call it a trap site and
what you do is we essentially in inside
the the generated library for each
different function we have a truck table
and what it does is press says okay at
this exact offset within here if it
blows up here is exactly what it was
right so in this case let's say was
eight bytes into a particularly
function that you're making your memory
reference so we know that that could
provide a heap out-of-bounds trap what
this also tells us is that if we blow up
somewhere else that that is fatal right
this gives us a way of knowing whether
or not what we have provided like what
we have done is whether or not a
particular trap a particular like
segfault for instance is actually safe
okay right so bounds checking bounce
checking is like you know so this is
like a key part of how webassembly works
the problem with it is that
traditionally doing bounds checking has
been incredibly expensive right there's
a reason that many languages don't have
it built in that's actually like
entirely speed-related right there was a
read several papers recently about this
and some of them would see between like
2 and 10x slowdowns if you actually put
like strict bounds checking in to see
code for instance so like it's it's kind
of gnarly however whether somebody
actually does some things to make this
quite a bit better so if we if we go
back to like the virtual memory
abstraction from before one of the
things that makes virtual memory like
kind of difficult to do balance checking
with is that virtual memory has holes in
it you can map particular parts of your
virtual memory space and leave others
completely like unmapped
which means that if I want to do
something like this I want to write a
bunch of data right across the middle of
my memory region bounds checking that
gets really complicated so if you look
at look at this particular one I can't
just look at the front of it at the
beginning of it or the end of it right
because at the beginning in the end are
both actually totally valid places in
memory there's just multiple places in
the middle that are holds and so bounds
checking memory operations like this
gets really complicated yeah
so what's different about webassembly
and like the linear memory model for
this is that linear memory doesn't have
holes in it and it grows in exactly one
direction it grows up right so what this
means is that if there are no holes and
it's only growing in one direction and
we want to write into it
the only thing I need to bounce check is
the end of it right because everything
if the end is in everything else also
exists so that's a pretty that's like a
pretty powerful like mechanism there but
we can actually still do better than
that so one of the things that my team
and like the other folks working on this
compiler have been working on is this
concept of bounds check elision are
there folks in the audience who are
familiar with that concept
some of you good okay right so we can
still do better than actually having to
do all of these bounce checks so imagine
that we have some code like this it's
just I have an array I'm going to reach
17 elements into it and I'm gonna stick
a 64-bit value there all right let's
walk through how this would work in a
naive setup the code might expand to
something like this right so this is
this is the web assembly code for this
so we we get the local that is my array
we say that how does this work yes oh
right we're putting zero into it and
we're using an offset of 136 which is 8
bytes 64 bits times 17 great so if what
we had was a linear memory model like if
our implementation of that was just okay
I have several pages of space available
and I'm going to just that's all there
is to it like this I have this much
space and that's all I know then what we
would have to do would look something
like this and so what what is happening
here is that we actually have to do
multiple bounds checks despite the fact
that I just said that you wouldn't
necessarily have to do that so
essentially what happens here is we need
to first bounce check the base pointer
so that being the my array pointer and
then if that fails we throw what's
called a UD to so this is an explicit
bounce check in which if it fails we
throw a sigil right and so this is the
sigil this ud2 would show up in our trap
table and so we would know okay the
bounds check for this failed everything
is cool everything is safe then likewise
we need to check the offset plus the
size
as well so this is kind of a two-step
bounds checking thing going on here this
is kind of the naive way of implementing
a web assembly store instruction right
and so finally like the the actual
instruction is way down there way down
at the bottom
cool so if we were to however instead of
just saying okay
I have my linear memory and that's all I
have it's just linear memory if we were
instead to say okay let's put a guard
page at the end of it let's put a 4
kilobyte guard page at the end so what
what a guard page actually is is just
literally unmapped space but it's
unmapped based that we know exactly
where it is and how large it is what
does that do for us okay so going back
what this lets us do is something kind
of neat it lets us just check the base
pointer all right so if we know for
certain that there is a 4 kilobyte guard
page at the end of our linear memory and
that there will always be one there it
means that as long as the offset that we
were going off of from the base pointer
is within 4 K we don't need to look at
it right because what we know will
happen is if we access something that is
within that 4 kilobyte region we will
get a seg fault and we can recover from
that seg fault because again we know
that it's safe so it's okay so yeah we
don't have to check the offset on set
instead we just check the base pointer
so what that actually gets us is that
the fact that let's say we had several
instructions in a row that looked like
this right
effectively all we would actually need
to do is check that base pointer once
because we would know that as soon as
that base pointer is inside the memory
and as long as any of the offsets are
not greater than 4 kilobytes will be
find cool so that's like one form of
bounds checking elision let's let's go
one step further though what if we
instead of having a 4 kilobyte guard
region we had a 4 gigabyte guard region
which might seem crazy but it turns out
that computers have a lot of virtual
memory space so you could actually fit I
believe it's roughly 32,768 of these
into a single process even having like
guard regions that large so what would
that get us
well okay we have this line again and
that's what it would compile to right so
given the fact that webassembly only has
32-bit pointers we can say for certain
that if something is 30 we have memory
region there's 32 bits wide then we know
that it can't possibly address anything
that is beyond that and so we don't need
to bounce check it at all
so this is like one of the ways that
we're using in order to like take
webassembly code and make it like really
fast which is pretty cool ok enough
assembly I guess I'll be done so how are
we doing this at the moment well much of
the work of this is actually being done
in a project called crane lift and so
crane lift is a project that was started
by Mozilla last year with some like
really great compiler people working on
it it's supposed to be one of the one of
the newer like jet engines that are
coming out we're working with them on it
because we want to use this for our
ahead of time compilation engine you can
kind of think of critera
crane lift as like a smaller lower level
version of LLVM with safety guarantees
built into it interestingly like someone
actually tried to do this with LLVM a
number of years ago it was called
pinnacle pinochle if anyone remembers
that thing so this is a portable yes
portable Knakal was something that was
built into Chrome and so they were
essentially had a fork of LLVM in which
they had guaranteed that all of the
memory operations all the operations in
there were actually safe it turns out
that maintaining that is a [ __ ]
nightmare
so that's crane lift and so as mentioned
before the the project that we are
working on which wraps crane lifts and
makes it actually runnable like because
crane lift is essentially just putting
out like raw native code and so it
requires quite a bit of tool chain to
make all of this work and so we'll be
releasing this at some point in the near
future but great so to review
isolation incredibly important for the
way that we do programming today right
especially when it comes to
multi-tenancy or even just like the
reliability of systems that you actually
do trust isolation is like critical
right web assembly is pretty awesome so
the reason again
and why like webassembly is super
exciting for me and I think for a lot of
people it's not just the fact that cool
we have like a new language in the
browser but rather again that it's a the
it's a widely agreed upon intermediate
representation that many different
languages can use and that's super
exciting to me but like really one of
the main points of this talk was
actually just I had spent a lot of time
thinking about like a mental model for
isolation like the the whole thing where
okay it's not just about memory it's
actually about like control flow and so
on and that like we can actually think
about a lot of these things and
abstracts so that was the point I was
mainly trying to get across today but
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]